Now what is a tuple?
And this also comes from mathematics.
This word is used.
It comes from mathematics. What is a tuple referred to?
And what's a good use case of a tuple in Python?
Well
Let's talk about some of the problems of lists. So we have some context a
list is a mutable data structure.
Which means you can add to it you can remove from it and you
can modify the contents of a list.
What what else do we know about tupus it is index
based?
So if you want a particular element, you have to know it's index.
These are the indices.
Okay.
Now a two pole is very similar to a
List, but it is immutable.
So once you declare a tuple you cannot remove from
it, you cannot add to it, but it is also in the expressed.
So what would use a tuple when you don't
what you want to create something and not change it again?
A simple example would be days of the week.
Right. These are immutable.
So we start with Monday and go off to a
Tuesday.
You know you get the idea.
So if intention is to create something that will remain unchanged.
And a data structure was elements will remain unchanged
throughout the entirety of the program. Then you would use
a tuple.
But again, you can still use keys in the
form of indices to access a particular.
element
And so if you want the last day of the week.
You put seven but since we come from 0 that
will be six.